Now, this is the plan I'm proposing.
It's a plan that incorporates ideas from many of the people in this room tonight,...
...Democrats and Republicans.
And I will continue to seek common ground in the weeks ahead.
If you come to me with a serious set of proposals,...
...I will be there to listen.
My door is always open.
But know this:...
...I will not waste time with those who have made the calculation...
...that it's better politics to kill this plan than to improve it.
I won't stand by while the special interests use the same old tactics to keep things exactly the way they are.
If you misrepresent what's in this plan,...
...we will call you out.
And I will not accept the status quo as a solution.
Not this time.
Not now.